[Music]
got something to show me go get it go
get it I might have one of the only dogs
in the world that doesn't like balls he
doesn't like to fat she doesn't like to
chase unless it's piggy puppet then
that's a pleasing to city canto we just
got some fake grass this job is
completely destroyed is outside backyard
area so we had to get rid of all of the
bark
maybe not this vigorous what's this
Manny you want this ball go get it
wow are you attacking me
you're so vicious I think somebody
forgot that he's a wise statement poodle
Manny are you a statement poodle now I
have to go and never run a bunch of
errands I'm shooting a bunch of cooking
videos tomorrow
preparing for Halloween super excited
this is your last chance you have any
suggestions and things that you might
want to see for Halloween
tell me now I'm heading back to New York
at this weekend and I'm pretty excited
about it because I'm doing something
super super super super super
I can't even add enough supers about how
super cool it is
traffic why I've got a lot of tasks to
do today I have to go get a mani-pedi
because obviously it's extremely
important then I'm going to get a
haircut I also have to go to the grocery
store to get all of the supplies for the
baking videos tomorrow I'm a pretty
aggressive shooting schedule I'm trying
to shoot all seven videos in one day
I just had a realization I can't use
this with my phone even if it wasn't
still charging you guys are about to
witness the first time it's even gonna
play is it playing oh that sounds like
garbage what's wrong what's wrong with
it what's that sound
[Music]
we have ourself a dilemma is it the
phone is it the cord is it the aux cable
itself is it my car we're gonna need to
do a little investigating them but first
a manicure I usually don't get too
excited about manicures
but man this looks good
all right I'm putting our cut
[Music]
don't can't figure out what is aux cable
adapters not working
I don't have blue shoes pop
this dogs done crazy
Maddie's going crazy
what's happening Matthew we need a real
serious chat why have you got a muddy
mouth can we talk about it why do you
look like a slob here's the hair I'm
sure you can't tell any difference
that's the sign of a good haircut we
have some things going on here I was
trying to watch this Netflix show I'm
obsessed with it I want to finish it so
bad but I have so much to do that I keep
pushing play and then coming back over
here and trying to do my task and the
dogs going nuts is he's gone crazy
because Maddie's going crazy I wanted to
open up an Amazon box because it's gonna
be one of the most random things I don't
want to say it's the most random thing
I've ever wondered why Amazon but it's
up there what I thought was gonna be in
the box sometimes when I get really
sleepy like right before bed I go on
Amazon and I order things and I don't
remember until I wake up and I check my
email and it says your order has been
shipped and I get confused most people
sleep Walker open up drawers or globe
when their windows or end up on the
couch I shot one Hamilton I was having a
dream last night that I was unboxing
something and I woke up to a really
great email are you watching
this is the color I need to get my nails
next holy crap that is so sharp it it's
it's like it's cutting this tape like
it's not even there it's beautiful
[Music]
here's the thing this wasn't even what I
was expecting to unbox right now Amazon
this was a nighttime Amazon order
because I was always looking for a knife
when I'm doing my unboxing videos and I
wanted to spice it up I think this is
what look how sharp this is going to be
up there I'd also like to note this box
is extremely heavy in this box we have
I was expecting I ordered two hard
drives so I thought it was gonna be a
really funny opening because it was
gonna have marshmallow plus two hard
drives and I thought these were gonna be
surrounding the hard drives either way
what's happening right now have I lost
my mommy God that is so sharp you've got
to be so so careful knives are not
something to mess around with so we've
got marshmallows I need to set up this
table for tomorrow because we're doing
some crazy cooking videos I am and I
think I already mentioned it but it's a
pretty aggressive aggressive shoot
schedule but we're gonna do it because
you know what you make your own destiny
sometimes things can change sometimes
things can get in your way but a lot of
times those roadblocks will lead you
eventually to somewhere maybe that's
somewhere will be great
maybe that somewhere won't be great
things will usually work out in the end
you just can't sweat the small stuff
almost anything can be fixed
I feel like there was something else
that I wanted to talk to you guys about
but I really don't remember there is one
more thing the iPhone 7 his skate buzz
gate whatever it is they're calling it I
don't really talk on the phone that
often but tonight I was on a call and on
this call my phone started boiling it
was like it was actually so hot that I
was concerned that I was gonna burn
myself and then I kept hearing like this
hissing and buzzing sound in the speaker
like hi I forgot I was recording what's
it like to have zero attention span hope
you guys have a good day
I'm gonna go do these tasks are see you
guys later
we're ollie no happying she is back
there preparing our coffees cuz we have
no idea what kinds of coffee we're gonna
be drinking cuz we're doing the other
challenge can you show them what's back
there can you show them what's bad okay
okay good luck good luck oh look my
parents cookie-cookie were you